today we're gonna talk about how to
enhance your autophagy with coffee in
herbs now what is a autophagy it means
self-eat and it's basically a state or
condition where your body gets into
where it's recycling damaged proteins
and pathogens you have all the cellular
machinery inside your cells you have
mitochondria which is the energy factory
you have the DNA the blueprints
when these proteins become damaged they
can create more damage in your body so
your body has developed a system to
recycle them break them down with
certain enzymes and then create new
proteins it's quite fascinating but will
also help you eliminate pathogens
because they're not needed that's really
cool so that's what a autophagy is it's
a repair mechanism it reduces
inflammation extend your life it's
anti-cancer and anti-aging other than
that it's not that great I'm being very
sarcastic it's actually awesome most
people think about inducing a autophagy
when they're doing fasting my opinion is
that autophagy kicks in around 16 to 18
hours and fasting but I don't know that
for a fact that's just my opinion
there's really no studies to to tell you
exactly the time that you're gonna
induce a autophagy but this is my guess
exercise will also increase autophagy
and believe it or not coffee can also
help you to some degree now of course I
always recommend one cup not like a lot
of coffee simply because all that
caffeine is going to affect your sleep
and if you're not sleeping that's gonna
knock you out of autophagy so just a
small amount of coffee of course you
know if you want to put some sweetener
in it use erythritol or xylitol maybe
a little tiny cream but if you have a
choice between half and half in full
cream I would do the cream because it
has lower amounts of carbohydrates and
if you're just using a little bit of
cream it's not gonna be that big of a
deal
limiting the benefits of autophagy
sulforaphane this is a phytonutrient or
phytochemical
and cruciferous vegetables especially
broccoli or broccoli sprouts so you
could take these as a supplement and
enhance your autophagy now what about
consuming sprouts themselves or a little
bit of broccoli well the interesting
thing about autophagy is that not only
will a fasting induce of autophagy but a
very low calorie diet will also help
autophagy and if we look at all the foods
out there the foods that have the lowest
calorie and that have the highest
nutrients would be the vegetables I'm
mainly talking about the cruciferous
vegetables is because they have so many
different types of phytonutrients
vitamins minerals they have certain
amino acids they even have a precursor
to omega-3 fatty acids which is ALA
having a little bit of broccoli sprouts
could enhance your autophagy and then we
have the phytonutrient in green tea EGCG which will not only induce autophagy but
it's anti-inflammatory it has very
powerful antioxidants and it's very
anti-cancer then we have curcumin from
the spice turmeric that can help
increase autophagy as well as the final
nutrient resveratrol which is in several
things one is the grape skin it's also
very high in something called knotweed
very good for to extend your life it can
induce autophagy anti-inflammatory
antioxidant and of course because it's
in grapes it would just make sense that
you should just start drinking bottles
of wine before you go to bed and I'm
being very sarcastic again because the
alcohol will affect the liver and
prevent the benefits but as a plan-b
just take the grapes themselves and
squash out the inside where all the
sugar is and eat the skin of the grapes
and you'll be good to go or just take it
as a pill to make it easy so anyway I
just wanted to create this video to show
you that not only fasting will induce
autophagy but other things will do it
as well thanks for watching
hey we're back with another amazing
recipe no grains no sugar
totally keto there's no suffering in keto
absolutely not Karen and it's an immune
system builder absolutely you have to
check this out I think you should hurry
up watch the recipe and make it yourself
it's just so easy to be keto
what is it simple it's super simple we
hope you enjoy making it as much as we
are enjoying eating it